so congratulations thank you thank you
I'll try that's right you know I read
are you still on a high I'm still out
there it is uh it's still pretty good
still it's still sinking in but I'm
pretty up there yeah I was gonna say
what was your reaction when you realized
you want about the same reaction when I
got past the first episode because I
didn't think I was gonna make it at all
so you know it was uh it was pretty cool
I gotta say this is one of the most cool
things I've done and you know just from
the idea of the show itself was already
a surprise for me so it felt it felt
surreal I was gonna say where are you
keeping your trophy but you brought
yours I brought it with me I don't know
one of the better things of my outfit
right now so you know big old trophy
lights up as you can see super family
I'm all about it um where are you where
are you planning on keeping this thing
uh right in between my Grammys
it's right up there so you know same
material all that gold in one place
it'll look pretty cool you know me I
like a lot of gold all in one place
you're gonna keep it with your Grammys
like it's as important to you as a grant
that's a big deal yes I mean it really
you know enabled me to possibly get
another one so yeah absolutely just as
important it put another light into my
career and it you know introduced me to
people who otherwise probably wouldn't
wouldn't have heard of me so you know
this is the highest rated show in seven
years and you know we've got a lot of
viewers so if we probably are going up
for another Grammy I would love that
that would be amazing
what was your first reaction when they
asked you to do the show I mean was it
something you were on board with
immediately or did you have to be
convinced I was got on board with it I
mean obviously the initial idea when it
came from a manager who was terrible at
explaining anything it sounded super
dumb and you know they'd send me clips
of the Korean version and things of that
nature and it all made sense afterwards
so I was like oh yeah I get to wear a
costume too absolutely I love costumes
anytime I get a chance to wear costume
it's having it well you need to give
your manager a big thank you obviously
yeah
a little bit and and and a lesson on how
to explain shows tell us about the
costume because you obviously had a hand
in choosing the costume yes I named a
costume the the costume was already
designed so you know I think I'll pick
the most difficult costume you know and
then the the least revealing costume
because you know everybody else had the
mask and just clothes just normal
clothing that you can see their body you
can see what they're doing and me you
couldn't see anything because I was just
in a big tube so even if I tried my
hardest to do all these big movements it
just wouldn't translate outside of this
giant but I picked it because it was
super silly and I love silly things so
you know it's coincided with my
ridiculous brain how hard was it to keep
the secret I mean from your family or
friends I already talked to anybody
anyway so it wasn't that difficult to
keep secrets you know you know my mom
knew and you know my true fans they
already knew the voice it was pretty
difficult as far as out in public on
social media and stuff like that it was
definitely difficult for that but you
know in my inner circle my friends
family and stuff like that at any point
like you want Ori or you had like I
almost lived up the first night I almost
tweeted about it I was like about the
tweet about the premiere and I was like
oh wait I can't I can't do that and then
I saw other celebrities talking about it
I was about to retweet it's just so easy
to hit one retweet button and now this
that was difficult for sure
I almost almost slipped up like a bunch
of times tell us about when you realize
that you beat Donny Osmond and Gladys
Knight it wasn't a great feeling it
wasn't a great feeling to to beat the I
mean to beat somebody you really you
know grew up to and a note somebody you
analyzed and it just won a great feeling
but it was the most amazing feeling at
the same time because you know people
understand the scale and the grit it
took to get that far and you know in
order to get up there where I was I
think that was it was an accomplishment
but man that I feel bad
feeding GLaDOS is like a pretty big a
comment that some pretty big
accomplishment and yeah I just I don't
know I don't know I don't know how to
feel about it it's this it's very
confusing situation there
well everyone said it's true you so have
such a beautiful voice I mean where's
there a moment when you realize that you
were gonna win this not really not
really I didn't think I mean every
episode I was I was thinking about self
man this is this is where I'm going this
is where they kick me off right here I
never knew so you know it was a like I
said it was surreal and I had no idea
now that you've been a contestant
they're getting picked up for a second
season to plan on coming back as a judge
no question that definitely we'll take
that offer if it comes through today
well I'm I'm all for it
you